welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down the ending of Blue Beetle
choice
the new DC movie is now out and
throughout this video we're going to be
going through what happens at the end
and what's going on with the DCU in
general it's all a bit of a mess and
there's lots of things kind of up in the
air at the moment with a quote-unquote
reboot headed up by James Gunn firstly
though I want to touch on those posts
credit scenes what they could mean for
the future and yeah everything that I
think could be happening with the Blue
Beetle we're going through it all but
obviously heavy spoilers ahead so if you
don't want anything ruined then I'll
recommend you turn off now but out of
the way huge thank you for clicking the
video now let's get into Blue Beetle
okay
[Applause]
okay so the film follows Jaime Reyes and
his family as he finds himself in
possession of an ancient alien Relic
known as the Scarab bonding to Jaime
begins a symbiotic relationship with him
that grants him an exoskeleton with
Incredible Powers taking on karapak's
indestructible man and his boss Victoria
called Jaime learns to get a grips with
his new abilities and he becomes a hero
for Palmyra City now this is a fictional
place from the comics and originally the
character was from El Paso however the
comic company wanted to give him a place
to call his own which is of course in
the same vein As Cities like Gotham and
Metropolis bit of trivia for you but
Palmyra city was actually created for
the movie but it appeared first in the
comics due to them being able to pump
them out quicker home of Court
Industries this is a big location that
most of the movie centers around with it
sort of being like how the Oz court
building kept popping up an Amazing
Spider-Man it's here where Jaime gets
the scar from and this is given to him
by Gwen State sorry Jenny cord and we
actually visit the mansion that she grew
up in at one point in the film and it's
here that we get a tease towards her
Father Ted cord Ted is a big character
from the comics and he was the second
version of the Blue Beetle now if you
recognize the guy in the painting this
is because Jason sudokus has actually
been cast in the role though he doesn't
appear in the movie per se we do get
some lines of dialogue that he spouts
off which take us into the mid-credits
scene after taking over Court Industries
due to karapak self-destructing himself
in Victoria we see his journey says that
she's going back to her old home Jaime
officero left and from here we curd into
that mid-credit scene and during this a
broadcast has played out and we get Ted
cord in a sort of almost zod-like
hologram message thing saying that he's
alive we then focus on the Classic Blue
Beetle suit and it lets us know that
should they make a sequel then he's
gonna be coming back thought to be dead
throughout the movie This teases that
the character will return and if gun
decides to make a follow-up then that's
the way things are gonna go I'm kind of
in a weird place with DC post credit
scenes at the moment and I actually
looked back at all their past movies and
realized how pointless that most of
their inning teasers were Justice League
teased the Legion of Doom and
Deathstroke which is never gonna happen
Snyder's way better version to you said
as well and also the nightmare timeline
which that that's going down now both
shazams teased Mr Mind Black Adam had
Henry Cavill flash ended up showing us
George Clooney and I'm sure there's
another one that I can't remember does
Wonder Woman 1984 count will have to see
but either way that's at least six
teasers to things that have been
mothballed and due to the opening
weekend predictions for this I doubt
it's gonna set the world on fire either
I'll enter my local Cinema and they had
absolutely no showings there and then
had to travel to the next cinema where
North Shields I was doing four for the
whole day opening day and you compare
this to movies like Mission Impossible
which had showings every hour in
multiple formats and it doesn't feel
like the studio has got that much
confidence in it unfortunately I think
DC saw what happened with the box office
of their last films and just kind of
dumped it out here but gonna still
remain adamant that Reyes will remain in
his movie so if Ted Court does come
across and you probably want to know
everything about him and if I I'll admit
I've been a bit of a Negative Nancy so
for the next part of the video we'll
just focus on who that character is now
the original Blue Beetle was named Dan
Garrett and like a lot of superheroes
tragedy struck his life from a young age
his father was a police officer who was
killed by a criminal and this made him
vow to become a crime fighter this was
all shown in the mystery man comics of
1939 which were then later reprinted as
part of the Blue Beetle annual that was
by Charlton comics and technically they
didn't own the full rights to the
character they just purchased the
printing plates which gave them somewhat
the ability to put the character out
there now during 1964 Charlton yeah they
just said [__] it and decided to create
a new Blue Beetle with them just adding
an extra tea to Dan Garrett's surname
they scrapped his powers and also his
origin story and came up with a new one
in which he was an archaeologist this is
someone Rift upon in the opening of the
movie with us getting newspaper
clippings that show Ted Court funded his
research that's in the scientific review
which has an atom symbol on it and we
also get one from the Daily Planet we
find out Garrett found a mystical Scarab
in Egypt and just like the comics that
bonded with him before moving on to
Jaime now where Ted Court comes into it
is that Charlton decided to get rid of
Garrett in 1966 and they then replaced
him with head chord cord was a former
student of Garrett and he was actually
at his side when Garrick died perishing
in battle Garrett went to pass this
Scarab on to him but it was unable to be
transferred over now Sheldon eventually
ended up getting bought by DC and with
him came a lot of characters like the
question and Captain Adam Alan Moore
actually originally wanted to use these
as part of a series he was working on
but DC shut that idea down because of
what he was planning to do with them in
the end he still continued ahead with
his story but he made somewhat plays on
their characters which had gone to
become Watchmen as record he's a genius
level inventor who as all manner of
gadgets and gizmos at its disposal more
brought all these over for night Island
Watchmen and even Archie is based on
courtship the bug after Garrett's death
head took the scar with him but he
didn't really use it it appeared in both
crisis on infinite Earths and The Death
of Superman but it only ever really
reacted when it was attacked I can kind
of see in the films that he'll become a
sort of meant at a high me and
potentially the pair together could
study the Scarab and see how it works
that's kind of how the comics went too
with a Scarab skipping from dad to Jaime
and granting both with its incredible
abilities I think the next movie will
likely Center on them searching for Ted
which is when they'll use his
intelligence to truly get the backstory
of its Origins kinda what I think
they're doing with the 10 rings in Shong
Chi and we may learn more about the
alien origin and where things could be
going in the future now the post-credits
scene of the movie is more sort of an
in-joke for the film whether it's
getting a clip of claymation version of
El Chapo in Colorado this was a Mexican
superhero comedy that added in the the
70s and it's also what Jaime's uncle
named his machine after which has the
red and yellow from the character's
costume on it now this is more just kind
of giving a little nod towards Latino
culture and it pops about one Pawn in
the movie with Rudy's machine playing it
over the security footage we can catch
scientists and security guards watching
it one of which is played by Felipe
Esperanza and this is just kind of
bringing things full circle from there
and ending the movie with a little joke
now as for the future of the DCU I think
that unfortunately guns kinda stuck
between a rock and a hard place with it
that's not a rock Black Adam joke by the
way now he was of course brought on in a
time where a lot of movies still had to
be released and thus he has to go out
and promote these like they're part of
his Universe however it is kind of
becoming clear that the audience
interest just isn't really there with
this stuff and judging by his slight
announcement I think it's gonna be a
while before we see these characters
again the last seven DC films connected
to this universe have all flopped and
due to the low predictions of Blue
Beetle I unfortunately feel like it's
gonna be the case here too kind of makes
you wonder what's going on at the
company because I I don't know how many
flops in a row can take for them to
realize like maybe we should just hard
reboot it back in the day if a film did
badly it just didn't get a sequel but
now studios are so tired of their shed
universes that they refuse to let go if
Aquaman 2 bombs then that's gonna be
nine flops in a row which is absolutely
insane when you think about it you think
third movie and they'd start to realize
that but guns made it clearly still
going ahead with bringing elements of
these other movies across that he thinks
works we of course recently had galgara
discussing how they were putting things
in place for Wonder Woman 3 and Margot
Robbie's being announced as remaining as
Harley Quinn we of course have
Peacemaker or Walla and some of the
other characters continuing but there's
some new faces too in the form of Batman
and Superman I kind of feel like they
should have just called it a recast
instead of a reboot because it doesn't
really seem like much is changing when
you get down to the Brass tax of it
Henry and Ben are both out but to be
honest it's deemed a couple of years ago
that that was the case anyway both came
back for Black Adam in the flash with
Ben also getting a scene in Aquaman 2
that we Nano has been cut still though
there's been talks for years of them
being out so I think they could have
just had gun take over without ever
announcing a reboot now the biggest
criticism with Warner Brothers handling
of DC has always been the mismanagement
behind it unfortunately when characters
are announced as being in one week and
out the next it doesn't seem like things
are even going that smoothly now though
they're making a lot of noise about how
these characters are staying in the
universe I think behind the scenes there
will probably be a lot of panic because
of how much money these movies are
losing it's been reported that this year
Warner Brothers has lost a billion on
the three movies they've released in the
DCU and they must be wondering whether
to salvage it or scrap it it was once a
time when you just had to say something
was a superhero movie and people would
Pile in to see it but now on the whole
list yeah most of them have done worse
in other franchises except for Indiana
Jones that makes you wonder if the
interest for a shared comic book
universe will even be there by the time
we hit Superman Legacy and I can imagine
behind the scenes that everyone's kind
of a bit worried looking at Joker and
the Batman both did big numbers and
they're the two DC movies released since
the shed Universe began that aren't
connected to it this was the company
that started doing crazy stuff because
Man of Steel and Batman v Superman
didn't hit the numbers they were after
but I think if they got those films box
officers today they'd actually be over
the moon now I know I'm probably coming
across as super negative on this but I'm
just trying to be realistic and think
about how this is shaping the industry I
actually think that the poor performance
of comic book movies in general will put
studios off investing so much into them
going forward as they're no longer the
Golden Goose that they once were now for
argument's sake let's say gun in the
studio say [__] it this is the plan and
we're keeping these characters around I
actually think they might be
incorporated into more creative ways
rather than just getting their own solo
movies the team ups to me all the ways
to go and with us knowing what's coming
in getting slight I actually think
that'll be the way that they're going to
be handled guns said there are still
some movies that haven't been announced
yet and I think this will probably be a
Justice League or JSA film the ladder
was one of the best parts of Black Adam
and with Walla being behind them that
could be something that's brought
forward into this brand new universe or
well not really brand new but you know
what I'm saying Garrett was in the
Golden Age GSA team and blue Beetle's
been part of the JLA jli Young Justice
and Teen Titans as well think they will
probably just combine it into either a
young justice or JSA thing and I think
team-ups are the way to take the movies
that maybe don't break the bank at the
box office they can combine the members
so you've got someone say really popular
like Batman with the slightly lesser
known ones that are used in more of
these lower performing movies now they
could all boost each other up in these
team up movies and it would help to
build up their names and that's not
saying Blue Beetle isn't popular because
I know he's got a big fan base but yeah
just with this being his first movie it
might be the way they do it I think the
JSA will actually play a big part and
guns plans too as they were brought up
again at the end of Shazam 2. that was
in a post credit scene that James gonna
proved and we know that he's been nixing
others so they don't promise certain
things for example Henry Cavill Michael
Keaton and sashikai were supposed to be
at the end of The Flash but they ended
up reshooting this to include George
Clooney so leaving this in shows how he
probably hoped that in some ways it
could be brought up again in the future
and you might get these characters
teaming up rather than purely solo
stories I think that's probably the
smarter way to go as they might not be
selling many tickets on their own but as
one United group they could still push
things a lot more as for the film as a
whole I think that it's definitely one
of the stronger ones of these DCU films
that's been released the last couple of
years the entire family angle works
really well and even if I don't think
the movie hits the mark on everything it
still has a lot of things in it that
deserve to be brought across to feature
movies there are moments where you can
tell this was a originally show up at
HBO Max and with a bigger budget and
push involving these characters in the
future I think it could do even better
sholo maraduanya does a great job as
Blue Beetle and it's nice seeing him
getting the spotlight after killing it
in Cobra kaifiers the family are great
too and I think they added another
dimension to the film that often isn't
shown in superhero movies unfortunately
this kind of leads into the cliches of
stuff like your family's what makes you
weak and so on and you can probably tell
beat for beat exactly how this movie's
gonna go I think the main issue the
movie has is that it feels derivative of
a lot of other films that have come
before and probably done it better
there's lots of things in the film where
they clearly looked at Spider-Man and
the MCU as a whole and thought how can
we redo this with the Blue Beetle Air
instead this is very much what I'd call
a phase one movie and it comes with both
the positives and negatives that that
had there's some humor that works and
sometimes doesn't and also some
underdeveloped villains that don't quite
live up to their potential there was a
time in the MCU where the bad guys
basically just ended up becoming the
heroes in a different colored costume
and this is something that happens here
too I think the positives far outweigh
the negatives here and there's
definitely a lot to like Bruno marsin is
brilliant as Jenny cord and this is a
film with a really strong Supporting
Cast that has happened to push you to a
level that it might not have reached
without them there's also carapax
indestructible man as well too who in
the comics was an archaeologist which
ties into the whole Dan Garrett thing
they kinda make him a sort of craving
the hunter slash Iron manga figure here
and it's an update that brings a pretty
obscure character to the Forefront in an
exciting way at the end the backstory
really makes you feel for him and I kind
of feel I could have dropped that
earlier in the movie to make you more
attached to the character Susan Sarandon
is just sort of like we are using
technology to create weapons kind of
things and now they have her do some
really evil over the top stuff to make
her look evil it's just kind of the the
racist evil CEO stereotype again all the
family stuff works really well though
especially with the emotional beats that
happened with Jaime's dad and tried to
save his home stuff like this that's
what makes it stand out and I think they
could have leaned into elements like
this a lot more as unfortunately at the
moment it just feels like another comic
book movie instead of being a must see
one that third act just falls into the
same cliches that have dog comic book
movies for the last couple of years and
it's an uninteresting CGI fight that
makes the movie become mundane when it
had so much potential even lines like
you should have killed me when you had
the chance I need to find my purpose
maybe this found you for a reason just
kind of make the movie feel like stuff
you've seen before which is what often
holds back new Heroes due to creating
instant comparisons instead of allowing
it to feel fresh now it unfortunately
got released during a very weird time in
the DC movie slay because there's just a
massive confusion surrounding the entire
thing it's supposed to be Standalone but
it may be part of the dceu which is
something Warner Brothers have decided
to get get rid of it's also potentially
part of a rebooted universe and someone
who may not be the first DCU hero
everything is just kind of instead of
luck surrounding it but judging it on
its own Merit yep I think it was good
also an ignorant secretary calls him
Jamie Ray s at one pointers because
everyone calls him Jamie when when they
first read his name they also have a big
belly burger box too Jaime graduated
from Gotham law soups in the flash I
mentioned and yeah lots of nods of the
comics I just couldn't find other places
to slot them in the video now I think it
was a risky move taking this from Max to
the big screen but I do think it
deserves the push as there are things
General audiences will enjoy those are
not burned out on comic book movies will
probably like this a lot but I doubt
it's Gonna Change anyone's mind who's
starting to feel the genre is becoming a
bit tired as Rudy says in the film blue
beetles like Batman just not as good and
yeah kind of feel that's a good summary
of Where the film stands in the DC
Pantheon of movies in the end Blue
Beetle was a solid movie that I think is
definitely worth checking out and
because of that I'm giving it an 8 out
of 10. I feel it's probably the best way
they could have introduced the character
but unfortunately it comes at a weird
time where superhero movies feel like
they're in a strange Place had it been
released a couple of years back I think
it would have had way more interest but
yeah everything going on with DC and
just the genre in general probably held
it back also I know it's like first
weekend and I've been a bit Doom and
Gloom but I am hoping this has legs and
it just kind of yeah yeah you know it it
doesn't make its money back it's just
those opening weekend predictions
pre-ticket sales and just the way DC
movies have been performing in general
it's all kind of down at the moment and
yeah I don't know if this is gonna save
it kind of feel like they could have
just sat on this and maybe waited until
Superman Legacy was out and then dropped
it after but yeah I keep going back to
something I've said numerous times where
there was no need for gun to announce
the reboot until after these movies were
out man could have easily waited until
January 2024 without anything changing
but yeah I'm going off track and
obviously let me know your thoughts
below and whether you agree with us or
not if you want to get some heavy
spoilers merch we've also got our
t-shirt line located just below the
video that will let you pick up all
kinds of tops from the heavy spoilers
history we've got our Theory time on
there House of the Dragon stuff Marvel
teas and a lot more we drop new designs
on there all the time so definitely keep
an eye out for them and huge thank you
for your support now if you want
something else to watch you've got a
breakdown of the Doctor Strange leaks on
screen right now let's talk about a new
report discussing what's coming in that
film heavy spoilers ahead for that one
but yeah lots of things to talk about
and hopefully I see over there right
after this about the way huge thank you
for sticking through the video I've been
Paul and I'll see you next time see you
chump
hello